اسطنبول مجددا كما يعرف هي الخزانه
الانتخابيه الاكبر في تركيا واكبر وعاء
انتخابيه ايضا ما الذي يهم الناخبين اكثر
فيها في هذه المرحله
لا شك مريم يعني انه كما قال عمر الوضع
الاقتصادي والتضخم وارتفاع الاسعار
وانخفاض سعر الليره هو الذي يؤثر بشكل
كبير على كل الناخبين في عموم تركيا
وكلا الحزبين الرئيسيين سواء حزب الشعب
الجمهوري والعداله والتنميه يعد الناخبين
بانه سيتجاوز هذه الازمه وبانه سيتم تحسين
هذه الاوضاع الانتخابيه لكن هناك ما يميز
علاقه ربما حزب حزب العداله والتنميه بهذه
المدينه مدينه اسطنبول تعرفين ويعرف ربما
كثيرون بان هذه المدينه هي التي اوصلت رجب
طيب اردوغان الى سده الحكم بعد ان اصبح
رئيسا لبلديته عام 94 وهذه المدينه التي
كانت تعاني من الكثير من المشاكل والاهمال
وسوء الخدمات التي كانت تقدمها البلديات
المتتاليه لهذه المدينه النجاح الكبير
الذي حققه هنا هو الذي جعل الشعب التركي
ينتخب حزب العداله والتنميه عندما اسس
وتقدم في اول انتخابات برلمانيه عام
اردوغان ركز وبالتالي حاول اردوغان ان
يستفيد من هذا التاريخ بالحديث مرارا
وتكرارا وتذكيرا المواطنين بالخدمات التي
قدمها سواء عندما كان رئيسا للبلديه وبعد
ان اصبح رئيسا للوزراء وبعد ان اصبح رئيسا
لهذه الجمهوريه تحدث بشكل كبير عن الفرق
بين الفتره التي كان يحكم بها والفتره
التي سبقت وكيف كانت الخدمات سيئه حول
تذكير الناس يقول طبعا هناك لان هناك خشيه
من ان هناك اعداد كبيره من الشباب تدلي
باصواتها لاول مره لم تعش تلك الفتره التي
عاشتها الفتره السيئه التي عاشتها هذه
المدينه وبالتالي حاول ان يذكر الناس بتلك
الفتره ايضا ربما بعيدا عن الازمه
الاقتصاديه التي يراهن عليها او تراهن
عليها المعارضه وقدرتها على حل هذه الازمه
والتي تقول بان هذا الحزب الذي يحكم منذ
21 عاما لو كان قادرا على حلها لا حلها
قبل ان ينتخب مره ثانيه لكن الحزب الحاكم
ايضا يستفيد من نقاط اخرى وتباينات
وتضاربات في العلاقات والتحالفات داخل
المعارضه للاستفاده من هذه التباينات
واقصد هنا طبعا ان التيارات الموجوده داخل
هذا التحالف مختلفه متباينه وربما متضاده
بالاضافه الى دعم حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي الذي يوصف بانه جناح
سياسي لحزب العمال كردستاني حاول ان
يستفيد من هذه النقطه لجعل الناخبين
يصوتون لحزب العداله